oh yes great oh I got it Oh someone
there listen I'm armed and I've got AIDS
so it's not worth it what okay what the
hell is going on here
that was hey listen these these onesies
they're making me break out I can't
really see anything I got to go to the
hospital
yeah I just got a call for Montez says
that Julie is going around firing people
well yeah she is and you know what Rudy
says when you leave the third-string
kicker and the quarterbacks is position
someone's gonna get sacked just shut up
and follow me I want to know what's
going on okay so we take my hand
actually hey Alice hold up what one
thing right quick what's it what's up
Adam get down from there right now I
don't have to listen to anything you
have to say for the rest of my life
which is about to end because you fired
me Alice so hear me world cuz these are
my last words if you take anything from
Adam the Top Gun demamps life take this
take it sleazy and I'm out write that
down
take it sleazy and I'm out or in my last
words and I'm killing myself what the
hell does any of that even know why this
is your fault
you should've put me in charge hey it's
a dummy you're blind idiot wait what
what she was seeing here was not real
this was a demonstration of what strange
turns life can take when the powers that
be making some mrs. stupid the stupid
decisions
so put your fears aside for Adam he's
alive Hey